c'était ce matin dans les faubourgs de
pierres ramassées les armes au sol des
corps de combattants
ce sont des soldats d'ukrainiens qui
filme ils viennent assure-t-il d'enrayer
une attaque menée par des troupes russes
4 pas que nous allons repousser le shore
des bâtiments ont été détruits à bulle
il y a des morts et des
quelque kilomètres de là dans le centre
ville de kiev sous couvre-feu
les rues sont désertes
seuls circulent ces patrouilles des
forces de sécurité
sur les toits des bâtiments officiels
comme ici le parlement des snipers sont
en position qui elle tient toujours mais
ces dernières heures la pression russe
intensifie
la nuit dernière a été dure il ya eu des
bombardements de zones résidentielles et
d'infrastructures civiles
il y avait un seul bâtiment dans ce pays
ni à qui n'est pas considérée par les
occupants comme une cible à bille
octobre et parmi les cibles frappées et
bien ce défaut de carburant en flammes
dans une ville de la grande banlieue de
pied
il a été bombardé pendant l'année
pour échapper aux combats les habitants
se réfugient dans les stations de métro
dans les parkings cette chaîne de
télévision il ya même installé son
studio
c'est louche et ukrainiens nos
compatriotes ont vous salue sa les
conditions sont dures les lendemains
incertains mais c'est l'ukrainien tente
de faire front l'ambiance est bonne
entre nous c'est très très chaleureux on
est très proches les uns des autres on
s'entraide
à l'extérieur d'autres se préparent à
combattre ainsi ses habitants qui ce
matin confectionne des dizaines de
cocktails